alright welcome to another python 3
basics tutorial video in this video
we're going to be appending a file in
python i'll just say it again that
writing to a file will clear it while
appending will just simply add to it and
that said when you actually go to add to
the file you will still use dot write
okay so you only specify that you'll be
appending instead of writing when you
actually open the file and state your
intentions
so basically let's do append me
equals and we'll do
backs back uh backslash n for a new line
because we want to make a new line and
then we'll say new bit of information
and
um that's that so you don't have to
throw in this new line if you don't want
also what some people do is before they
actually write what they intend to write
they'll just very quickly do a dot right
um
new line like that and they'll call like
you know a pen file dot right um new
line okay so for example anyway let's
just continue on with our new line here
so we'll say a pen file equals open
and again we're gonna open
um
whoops
i'm going to open example file.txt
and this time we're going to specify our
intention
a to append and then all we do is append
file dot right like i said we still say
dot write it's just we
we've writing in append mode basically
um what do we want to write append me
and here's what i was saying like if we
didn't have backslash n another method
you could do is append file
dot
um new line like that so there would be
a new line before the stuff that we were
writing
so sometimes adding a new line to a bit
of information can be hard or it just
depends it's kind of like a
stylistic sort of thing anyway when
you're done writing as usual append file
dot close we want to go ahead and close
the file so when you're done uh we'll
save and run that
and
if it runs it will
do nothing so to speak in your
output here but if we head over to
our folder we open up example file and
sure enough we have sample bit new line
and new bit of text a new bit of
information
so our appending worked out well
so that is appending to a file now
there's one more thing that we can do
with files and that's reading from files
so we know how to write to a file how do
we read from a file so that's what we're
going to be covering in the next video
as always thanks for watching